Speaker 1: One other little note on Herschel
Walker. We continue talking about Herschel Walker,
the Georgia Republican Senate
candidate, and his fake badge.
I have sort of like good news and bad news, I
guess. The good news at this point is that it's
really pretty transparent that his badge is fake.
This goes back to his debate with Raphael Warnock.
Raphael Warnock correctly accused Herschel Walker
of lying about being a law enforcement officer,
at which point Herschel Walker took out a badge
during the debate. Now, it certainly could be
a badge that was handed to him by some sheriff.
And he claims that it is, but it is meaningless.
It confers no law enforcement power. Herschel
Walker has not been and is not today any kind of
law enforcement officer authorized to do anything
at all. Well, Herschel Walker did another one of
these campaign events yesterday. And at this one,
he said that when you laugh at his badge, you're
laughing at the military and you're laughing at
law enforcement. That doesn't make any sense,
Herschel. But here he is saying it.
Speaker 3: Wasn't my badge. I love my
badge when he laughed at my father.
Never, ever really police in the country.
Speaker 1: How? Why? That
doesn't make sense, Herschel.
Speaker 3: Okay. Because they're the one who gave
me the grade. Because I support them. They support
me. So what we got to do is tell
them if they don't like our bullying,
we go from where we're not here.
Speaker 1: It's not that we don't like
the police. You are not a police officer.
Think about this unhinged word salad.
Speaker 3: You know, he in this country.
Speaker 1: He seems completely disoriented.
If you laugh at his fake badge, which confers
no law enforcement authority whatsoever,
you're laughing at our military and you're
laughing at our law enforcement. And then he says,
if you don't like our law enforcement, just leave.
Nobody's talking about how his fake badge connects
to any particular view about the police. He is not
a police officer. It has nothing to do with liking
or dislike liking police officers. We're not
even really laughing like we sort of are. I mean,
it's cartoonish and funny in a way, but we're
finding it sickening and very sad. But you know
what? Truly, the saddest part of all of this is?
It's embarrassing to even mention this. The race
is even closer now than it was before the batch
fiasco, before the abortion and badge fiasco.
Raphael Warnock was winning by nearly by nearly
four points. Warnock's lead is now smaller. It is
now only about two and a half points. Think about
what this says about in this particular case,
Georgia voters that before the entire abortion
fiasco started, it was roughly 48, 44. WARNOCK
ahead. For a very brief moment, Walker dropped by
like a point, and the race has now tightened to
where the difference between these two candidates.
On the one hand, incumbent Democratic Senator
Raphael Warnock, who understands policy, who
understands process, who understands reality,
is leading Herschel Walker by only 2.4. Walker
doesn't understand anything. Pulled out a fake
badge, claims to be a police officer, claims to
be authorized to work with police if something
happens, which doesn't even mean anything
that claims to be pro-life with no exceptions,
and yet paid for a woman's abortion and then
urged her to have a second abortion, which
she did not do. And it is 2.4 points. This says
as much about the Georgia electorate as it does
about the candidates. And our voicemail today has
to do with exactly what I'm talking about here.